[Music]
prince philip the husband of reigning
british monarch queen elizabeth ii
has died he was 99 years old
flags at the at buckingham palace are
flying at half-staff
the royal family has entered an official
mourning period
while on their golden wedding
anniversary the queen described the
prince as
her strength and stay also known by his
title the duke of edinburgh prince
philip spent more than 70 years by her
side
well the royal family issued this
statement an hour or so ago where it
said
it's with deep sorrow that her majesty
the queen has announced the death of her
beloved husband
his royal highness prince philip the
duke of edinburgh
has passed away peacefully this morning
at windsor
castle one eye from andrew simmons who
takes a look back at the life and legacy
of the duke of edinburgh he was by her
side throughout the longest reign of a
monarch in british history
for prince philip duke of edinburgh it
wasn't only a marriage but a life of
service to his wife
queen elizabeth ii born into greek and
danish royalty philip had a lonely
childhood
he was taken under the wing of the
british aristocracy
when he married the then princess
elizabeth in 1947 he was a promising
young naval officer
it was a fairytale wedding for a country
emerging from war and hardship
it all changed for the young couple when
elizabeth's father king george vi
died at only 56 years of age she became
queen
and philip in the words of his private
secretary looked as if the world had
fallen down on him
his naval career ended along with his
independence
prince philip was sort of forced into
making huge sacrifices he was very much
a man's man not someone who was
going to naturally fall into the
position of playing second fiddle and
walking two paces behind his wife and
calling her ma'am in public and and so
on and so began life in the queen's
shadow
hundreds of engagements a year he did
however manage to find time for his
own charities helping young people and
conserving wildlife
very energetic um a solve uh a sort of
scientific cast of mind
so those were sort of you know on the
positive side the
the attributes that people admired
sometimes though
you know that his his detractors would
would say that
you know some of his forthrightness
could come across as
rudeness philip did have a reputation
for embarrassing and politically
incorrect remarks
whether he was being rude about the
chinese or indians
or swearing at photographers often a
sideshow to formal occasions
yet even though an air of racism hung
over him
a staunchly royalist uk media generally
forgave him
he was certainly given a much easier
ride than politicians politicians who
tend to make
a racist or an offensive remark in this
day and age tend to have to apologize a
couple of days later because there's so
much pressure on them
but i've never known prince philip to
apologize for a remark and
i remember once he wandered over after
he said to an aboriginal leader do you
still throw spears at each other
and i saw him do this in australia in
2002 and
the next day he came over it made front
pages all over the world
and he just wandered over and said the
trouble with you is you've got no sense
of humor the complete absence of humor
so he wasn't going to apologize his
retirement from public duties came
in 2017 with a send-off from the royal
marines
[Music]
whatever the faults his 60 years of
public service was admired by many
people
while their marriage was said to have
had its ups and downs in the couple's
younger years
prince philip remained dedicated and
supportive
to the queen she'll receive immense
sympathy from a british public known to
view her
with respect and affection
let's cross live now to rory challenge
he joins us from london rory many
people paying tribute to the duke of
edinburgh
and they're emphasizing his long and
loyal service to
queen and country at this time
yeah i mean marrying the queen in 1947
uh that's a long long time ago he lived
a great many years
and a lot of those years were put in to
service uh
as one of the pillars of the royal
family one of the most important
institutions of the united kingdom and
of course the commonwealth
around the world as to whether
the uk uh is going to be united in its
uh
attitudes to prince philip what of
course it isn't um this is a country
which has
uh you know republican leanings from
certain sections of the population
i think many young people the left-wing
press
uh will perhaps think that his passing
needs no
more or less mourning than the death of
any 99 year old man but certainly in the
right-wing press
perhaps more conservative older britons
they will be
uh i think treating him with a lot more
reverence
going into his various uh qualities and
and mourning him
uh over the coming days and weeks and of
course we will hear
uh the kind of things that uh uh well
the kind of things from the british
government that we have just heard from
boris johnson and we can we can listen
to his uh his comments now
prince philip earned the affection of
generations
here in the united kingdom across the
commonwealth
and around the world he was the
longest-serving consort
in history one of the last surviving
people in this country
to have served in the second world war
at cape matapan
where he was mentioned in dispatches for
bravery
and in the invasion of sicily where he
saved his ship
by his quick thinking and from that
conflict
he took an ethic of service that he
applied
throughout the unprecedented changes of
the post-war era
like the expert carriage driver that he
was
he helped to steer the royal family and
the monarchy
so that it remains an institution
indisputably vital
to the balance and happiness of our
national life
uh rory the duke of edinburgh was very
old he died at the age of 99 so this
won't be a a great shock to many people
and
of course these funerals are planned uh
years in advance
but nobody really could have foreseen
the fact that uh
prince philip would have died in the
middle of a global pandemic how are they
going to
to hold this uh pomp and pageantry uh
the royal send-off while the country is
still in lockdown
well i think it will be a very different
uh funeral
than the ones that palace organizers
will have been preparing for pre-covet
of course
since covert hit they have had to come
up with a plan b
and what we know plan b won't entail is
the kind of things that we're used to
seeing
in royal funerals so processions through
the streets
crowds lining those streets waving flags
packed in tightly
next to each other perhaps a coffin
lying in a cathedral
with people processing past it and
paying their respects that
is most likely going to be impossible
at the moment in the uk because of coba
restrictions
funerals are limited to 30 people
maximum now that is going to endure i
think for
for at least a few weeks perhaps another
couple of months or so
so if we have uh prince phillips funeral
within that time it is likely to be much
much smaller and much
less public than the organizers have
been hoping for
so it is almost certainly going to take
place at
windsor castle and be attended by
a much smaller number of people perhaps
just close
family of course it also raises
questions about whether family overseas
at the moment
prince harry and meghan markle who have
had their differences with the royal
family
as we know over recent months whether
they will be in attendance these are
questions we don't know the answer to
yet
okay rory challenge there live from
london
rory thank you very much indeed
well let's take a closer look at the
life of the duke of
edinburgh prince philip was born on june
10 1921
in corfu to greek and danish royal
families
he was known as prince philip of greece
and denmark
well due to his mother's ill health
philip moved to england in 1928
and was raised by his maternal
grandmother and uncle
in 1942 he became a sub lieutenant in
the british royal navy
and was promoted to first lieutenant and
executive officer
aboard the hms wallace he participated
in the allied landings in sicily
during world war ii on november 20th
1947 he married princess
elizabeth at westminster abbey becoming
the duke of edinburgh less than five
years later phillips naval career
ended with the death of king george vi
and elizabeth's ascension
to the throne in 1979 his
uncle lord louis mountbatten was killed
in an ira bombing in ireland
on june 10 2011 philip celebrated his
90th birthday
and became the oldest serving royal
consort
later in life he suffered from various
ailments including a chest infection a
blocked coronary artery
and bladder infections and in august
2017
he attended his final official
engagement
before retiring from public life
well let's get more now from royal
biographer christopher
wilson he joins us on skype from
cornwall
uh cornwood rother in the united kingdom
it's good to have you with us uh
on the newshour just
i it's hard to get the the life of a 99
year old especially uh
one married to the the the reigning
british monarch into
approximately a minute 30 seconds but
there's a long and storied life
many achievements many impacts on so
many people
how do you think he will be remembered
not just by those in the uk
but but also worldwide
well i think um uh he is the person who
has actually saved the house of windsor
in my view
uh the queen when she came to the throne
was still in her early twenties
and uh she needed a strong guiding hand
behind her
she needed somebody who would support
her and
separate her from the old court who
who were a load of courteous who had
been around
for many many years and didn't want
anything to change
the british royal family needed to
change radically
in the post-war period and it was philip
who
came in with that dash and panache that
he's got
um that helped change things and of
course
he ruffled a lot of feathers he made a
lot of enemies uh
doing this but in in so doing he
modernized
uh the house of windsor which would
otherwise have been
in a very much more difficult situation
his
mother-in-law the queen mother who had
been queen elizabeth to
the previous king king george vi uh
was a conservative uh backward-looking
figure
uh determined that she should have
control of her daughter
queen elizabeth and philip managed to
brush her
to one side and allow queen elizabeth
to be her own woman and that is really
his greatest contribution
it did quite well his life and us were
hearing in tributes coming in
from from presidents of prime ministers
around the world
his life really has been defined by
service and and royal duty but
he did have a very distinguished
military career of his own and it must
have been very
difficult to set that aside for
a role in which he spent most of his
life walking
several paces behind his wife
it broke his heart he thought that he
had a good chance
that king george vi queen elizabeth's
father would live at least for another
20 years it would give him a chance
to rise up in the royal navy he was an
enthusiastic sailor he was a military
man
he enjoyed the challenge uh the the
manly world
that the being on her ship at sea
demanded
and he was particularly good at it he
was competent at it
and uh to suddenly have this career
ripped away from him
and then as you say uh to have to walk
two steps behind
the woman that was his wife was very
difficult what i will say is
that he was born royal and he knew that
if you became
prince consort that that was your job
two steps behind
uh quite it's but he he fulfilled that
duty he he never wavered from it as much
as he would have liked her dislikes that
he he
carried that role and function to the
very end
and he was an important uh support
for uh queen elizabeth uh not just in in
the roles he
he performed but also to help her steady
the ship through what's been
quite a turbulent rain it has to be seen
uh
the the royal family has endured many
challenges not just the abdication the
death of princess diana and it's
it seems it's going through another
turbulent time right now with uh
the story of uh prince harry and meghan
markle
well he was able to discipline people to
be able to
call on the queen's authority the queen
said you have to run my family for me
because i'm
uh running matters of state and so
he was able to keep a relatively strong
discipline
um on the younger royals i mean
things happened you know princess diana
prince charles you know the
the difficulties that they've had with
virtually all the children
um you can't uh you can't
escape that in any family but what he
was able to do was he was able to bring
up an order and discipline so that if
something went wrong the somehow a
corrective could be made
um simply because he would knock heads
together he would insist
that the royal family came first and
even if you were a prince or
princess your duty was to the crown
to the queen if you like but to the
crown that's your job
that's what you do and he was a
wonderful sergeant major figure in that
way
okay a royal biographer christopher
wilson thank you so much for
uh for shedding light and giving more
context uh
to uh the life of the duke of edinburgh
who has
passed away at the age of 99.
let's move to other news now and we're
heading to myanmar where there are
reports of tense fighting
as security forces crack down